un site flambant neuf de près de 7000 m²
cinq étages largement vitrée un espace
vert à proximité le futur siège social
de la caf des yvelines se veut moderne
dans un quartier complètement repensé à
côté de la gare de versailles chantiers
de faire un immeuble massif la caf se
sont en sorte quatre ou trois immeubles
reliés par des éléments en verre on
perçoit ça de l'extérieur ça formera un
ensemble je pense assez vivant donc on
pense toujours à l'urbanisme ce qu'est
ce qu'il ya autour
la pose de la première pierre du
bâtiment s'inscrit aussi dans une
nouvelle stratégie immobilière la caf
des yvelines disposera l'été 2010 8,2
deux sites pour l'ensemble du
département contre 8 il y encore trois
ans ainsi le siège social quittera saint
quentin en yvelines pour se rapprocher
du coeur administratif du département
pour les allocataires évidemment ce sera
bien plus simple de se rendre à la gare
des chantiers avec tous les moyens de
transport modernes et puis avec nos
partenaires aussi nos partenaires qui
sont effectivement naturel le conseil
départemental la préfecture qui sont
effectivement à la à versailles et qui
ne sont pas récents à saint quentin dans
les yvelines plus de deux cent vingt
mille personnes perçoivent tous les ans
des prestations sociales de la caf pour
un montant total de 1,2 milliard d'euros